five four three two one
welcome everybody to the genius brain
podcast I'm gonna switch my career into
ASMR now yeah so you hear the rain on
the windowsill
so we have a very very awesome guest
today and you may not know her from any
social media stuff but what started off
as somebody who was a fan and somebody
who I really really [ __ ] with like
number one I like to highlight people
that number one I very much respect
right and anybody who is a business
owner that started from a passion I
always want to highlight because I think
that a lot of the times when people look
at what I do and what you do and they
don't know how to get there you know and
because it's very scary opening up your
own business yeah it's right it's
frightening right yeah cause like when
we start off doing this thing you really
don't know what's gonna happen like the
only thing that you're you're banking on
is that you have the skill and the
talent to get you somewhere that you
want to be and it's hard sometimes
because like I feel sometimes I maybe we
buy into our own [ __ ] like this is
good but we don't know what public
perceptions like and specifically today
we have cat from cats Suites you are a a
business order that you work out of your
house out of my house yeah that's
[ __ ] crazy how did you get started in
this [ __ ] okay so in a nutshell and I'm
a sudden I'm in a really quick way this
was actually not even supposed to be a
part of my path oh really
no it's actually I used to work in a
hospital and the reason why I started
baking was because I got diagnosed with
cancer and then my doctor was like you
know it's a liability for you oh wow
yeah yeah so in 2012 well it's really I
had hit twice why yeah twice so in 2012
like you know oh my god so yes so in
2012 I was diagnosed with b-cell
lymphoma and what is it it's pretty much
like your B cells are diffused and large
and it's your
nodes and everything and I'm at the time
I was actually in college holy [ __ ]
so it was like three weeks of being in
college and I was like walking up these
stairs
and I was like out of breath and you
know the Asian side of you it's like all
these are flu-like symptoms like I'm
good
I'm gonna drink some freakin some hot
tea imma eat rice porridge I'm good and
then it started getting like
progressively like worse when I would
walk up the stairs and yeah I started
just getting like really short breath
and at the time I was like something's
not right and then one Saturday I woke
up was like hey I look at my sister
Vivian I go I need to go to the ER I
something's not right
because I've been coughing like this for
weeks not like three weeks now and I
can't get upstairs so then after that we
went to the ER and they end up doing
like an x-ray they did blood tests and
they found out that I actually had
pneumonia so I was running my thumb and
because I've been just like surpressing
was like oh it's just yeah it was just
the flu yeah I end up having ammonia and
then I got checked in and they did a a
procedure called like a fury fusion
where they have to take the fluid out of
your chest and that was supposed to help
me and whenever I went back to my room
all of a sudden my oxygen level went
from like 90 to like 50 and I couldn't
breathe anymore I felt like I was
drowning so they rushed me to ICU and
then they said you know what we actually
just found out that you have lymphoma
and there's a mass in your chest
so I have to I had two masses in my
chest and so for people who don't know
who what lymphoma is what does look fun
it's a blood cancer so it's it's just
like leukemia it's the Leukemia Lymphoma
or to the blood cancers and okay so yeah
so yeah I literally had surgery and woke
up and oncologists in my face says hey
you know you have cancer out at the time
I was 19 I was like nine oh my god I was
like 19 or going on 20 or something and
yeah and I they were like you know what
you're gonna have to actually stay here
and I had I have like scars and
everything but
had three chest tubes coming out of my
chest just constantly pumping out fluid
for I stayed in a mission for about five
to six weeks at Orange Coast Memorial
and they told me that on top of this
fluid stuff that needs to come out of
you you have masses in your chest and
you have stage three lymphoma and I go
oh my god so and at the time I was like
all right I honestly no family of mine
had cancer on both in I was like I don't
really know what to do but I'll you know
I trust I trust not there's a lokay
let's do what we have to do and they
told me that was going to be a rough
ride um that I had like 15 rounds of
chemo and then after that yeah it was
wrong how long did that take I was there
for six weeks so they did it every day
oh my god but there was there was
complications I kept hitting like
because you're bedridden and everything
and like I'm at like right now I feel
really self-conscious about my cousin a
little like heavier than I would like to
be but at that moment in 2000 in like 12
the lowest I hit was like 79 pounds and
it's in the book yeah because I couldn't
eat I couldn't I couldn't put anything
down I couldn't eat and naturally the
cancer will wither you away and at the
time before I even was admitted I was
losing weight and wasn't even trying so
I was like oh I don't you know I don't
know what's going on but whatever and
yeah so I did the I did the chemo and
then I they told me you know what after
you're done with the chemo I had a
little bit of setbacks because you're
bedridden I end up getting like an
abscess and then that prolonged it and
then another stepping stone was like
they said you can actually do outpatient
radiation so after the chemo I got out
of the hospital and it took it took a
while because there's a term called like
um like NPO where you can't eat anything
you can't honestly I haven't been and I
haven't been in a hospital in like six
years in the field oh my god but just
pretty much means you can't eat earthly
[ __ ] that's all really means
and I was Nupur genic and each pair
genic means you can't take in anything
that's like fresh because it might
contaminate like bacteria yes I couldn't
eat like I wanted freaking sushi I want
to like read me I couldn't like fresh
fruit was like you can't eat fresh fruit
ah yeah so it was one of those things
and then yeah and then I got out and I
did radiation and luckily been that I'm
with right now my fiance he was there
with me every single day during
radiation it was every day for about 16
weeks yeah and it was like two-hour
sessions and it was like straight to
your chest day like they tattoo in my
chest like the three areas where the
masses were yeah and I did that and then
yeah my life went on and I well let me
ask you something
number one like there's not a lot of
cancer in my family either for you
there's not so that probably blindsided
you a lot right yeah yeah I mean I heard
of my I heard of my my mom's cousin dad
passing away through I end up finding
out later on the he had leukemia but
that it was like my mom's cousins
father's so I guess my grandpa probably
yeah it wasn't that on a nun that all my
dad's side so it totally took me
blindsided and my age too oh yeah yeah
and I I'm not a smoker
I actually don't drink and or anything
so I was really like and I asked my
oncologist like how do you get and he's
just like it is yeah it's genetics is
environmental and and mind you I like
lived in the south so I don't know if
that had anything to do with it you know
but I mean I guess so I have a friend
right now that's coin I think she just
went through her last cycle of
chemotherapy for a breast cancer right
and thought behind that is how did you
kind of keep your spirits up doing that
through that whole thing because I I
can't imagine what that's like you know
like you for me I anyways from an
outside perspective I'm a very positive
person or I like to think that I am but
how did you kind of like maintain that
mental stability during that time you
had to go six weeks a the hospitals
rough yeah and
let me be honest with you like it's that
question it gets brought up so much
around my friends and my family people I
know because they asked me all the time
like can you give me advice for my
friend my aunt that's going through it
and for both times I was diagnosed
because I've all together I've had 30
rounds of chemo and then the stem cell
transplant at cedars-sinai so and to be
honest with you I hate to say this
because it I want to be that I want to
be there for Tibet I don't know how to
really sometimes I feel like [ __ ] for
not giving the the right answer because
for me I am a very positive person and
so throughout that whole first diagnosis
I didn't cry like I wasn't sure if I was
in shock like I didn't cry at all the
only time I cried was actually my hair
has always been it was a really big like
security blanket for me I had my hair
was like down to my butt growing up I
never cut it and I said you know what
[ __ ] this I'll see I'm not gonna give it
power like the chemo and all this like
everything that the nurses was throwing
at me like you're gonna feel like [ __ ]
you're not gonna feel well you're gonna
be ill ill you're gonna be this and that
I was like I'm not gonna let them I'm
not gonna be that percentage of people
so when I was in the hospital I actually
called my uncle who he does hair and I
said hey uncle can you come to my
hospital and come cut my hair for me and
buzz it off and I took that power for
myself and I had choice oh yeah I took
that choice and I said I'm not gonna let
this third because it's around round 3
whenever her hair starts coming out and
I said before I start this round 3 I
want you to cut my hair so he cut it in
a bob cut and then it and then it was a
really big dramatic change but how do
you feel when you lost your hair it was
really at first I was sad because like I
said it was a security blanket because
growing up I didn't feel pretty I would
grew up in like a very small town in
Mississippi and it's there's no Asians
there especially and the only Asians
that were there are my four my family so
I honestly wasn't around Asians and
people didn't really find you know venom
ease or Asian people attractive like
they used to call me
shengcún stuff and I'd really low
self-esteem but losing my hair I was
like you know what for some reason yeah
you you live in the OC right now though
right yeah and I'm talk about a [ __ ]
flip that dude that's basically Vietnam
dude I know I like Ben is like straight
from garden grove like he is Vietnam
he's more venom ease than me and he's
like Mexican white like but you know if
enemies in me but yeah it's it's crazy
cuz when I lost my hair I was like yeah
I was really sad because it was my
security blanket but at the same time I
was like you know what this show will
grow back and it did you know and then
the but the second time that I got
diagnosed like two and a half years
later I'm not gonna lie I was like hurt
I was like [ __ ] like my hair was already
like grown to like my shoulders I was
like damn again you know my doctor told
me like yeah this time it's gray zone
lymphoma and because my oncologist and
this that's what really like scared me
the most this time around this time I
was way more worried about the treatment
only because all the oncologists in
Orange County
UCI Orange Coast Memorial they had no
idea what to do so they had to send me
to LA and great my understanding of what
greys and lymphoma is it's non-hodgkins
lymphoma and Hodgkin's lymphoma combined
and it's a very low percentage of like
research and how mean I think the people
that get diagnosed is like 5000 and less
oh it's a very rare rare rare cancer
it's a combination of both and my
oncologist ended up telling me that
during the first diagnosis he thinks
that I had a second cancer running
inside of me but because they were
focused on taking out the first yeah so
I so they didn't know what to do and OC
they don't have I was surprised that
Orange County didn't have a stencil
machine so I was actually then I end up
being admitted to cedars-sinai for about
two months and I stayed there did chemo
and then the stem cell transplant so
yeah how did you fight through that cuz
it you know I think the first time when
you go through it I think it's I would
say easier but
easier yeah you know but then you know
you just fought this thing you survived
two years in that second round it's like
what yeah and and it that one was a
little bit was more emotional and I was
because I was like [ __ ] you know I'm at
that time I think I was like 22 23 and I
still young I go alright I can do this
already I already did it once I'm gonna
do it this time it's gonna be a little
bit harder though because I'm on the
comfort of my my city where I'm could be
or my family can visit me where my
fiancee can visit me I'm all the way in
freaking LA yeah and I was staying there
and I was there everyday and the nurses
and doctors kept telling me over and
over again look we're gonna have to
pretty much collect your stem cells
about 4 million stem cells from you take
it out we're gonna blast you with the
harshest chemo they have and kill every
good and bad thing in your body and then
after that we put back your healthy stem
cells into your body build rebuild your
body back up and that time it was a
little hard for me because my oncologist
and I told you I brought this up to that
this time around it was hard because the
stem cell transplant it makes you the
doctors tell you that you're gonna be
pretty much not be able to conceive
children and my my life calling and how
I always felt in my life because I I
wouldn't say I've had a troubled life it
wasn't violent growing up I was you know
in Bay st. Louis Mississippi I wasn't it
wasn't violent it wasn't like bad or
anything like that but I didn't my
parents had me very young 16 17 my mom
my dad they're like 42 and I'm 27
oh my god so they're young they were
like my siblings you know yeah and this
lovely podcast is brought to you by
purple you know how much I love purple
specifically my purple mattress and I
always talk about sleep because what is
sleep to us my friends how important is
sleep and if sleep is important in your
life then you know that your mattress
has to be important in your life and I
love my purple mattress the best
mattress I've ever had ever slept on and
my back feels
and tastic ever since i switched to a
purple mattress on top of that i sweat
at night i sweat no matter how cold it
is outside i'm sweating and i didn't
realize that the mattress that i had was
not helping me out and purple gave me a
high five and a quick quick help on that
because purple has the technology to be
soft and firm at the same time keep me
cool and help relieve pressure points on
my back because let me tell you the
science behind it is rocket science did
you know that the material is rocket
science based and my friends the best
sleep I've ever had
helps out with my mood helps out with my
with my weight loss controlling my
stress that's how important sleep is and
if once again sleep is important your
mattress is important as well so get on
that purple my friends you're going to
love purple and right now my listeners
will get a free purple pillow with the
purchase of a mattress that's in
addition to the great free gifts they're
offering site-wide just text brain to
eight four - eight eight eight the only
way to get this free pillow is to text
brain to eight four - eight eight eight
that's be are a I n two eight four eight
eight eight this podcast is brought to
you by skylight frame check it out man
holidays are coming around the corner
and if you're looking for a really dope
gift for your family especially if you
want to share memories and love you got
to get a sky light frame sky light frame
is a photo frame you can update
instantly by email from anywhere
it sets up effortlessly in about 60
seconds just plug in use the touchscreen
to connect to your wireless network and
enjoy sending photos the sky light is
super easy everyone in the family can
just email them to your personal sky
light email address and they'll pop up
in seconds now for me I actually got
this sky light frame for my parents
because whenever I go on vacations or I
travel all I have to do is send the sky
light or send to the sky light that
email address and the photos that I want
to send them pops up so when they have
the frame and they want to see things or
they want to see me they want to see me
and my fiance or the things that I'm
doing and they want to see photos they
don't have to wait for any other app or
you know
whatever just to see what I'm doing I
could send it to the email and it could
pop up in the frame so they could see it
in real time which is really really cool
so check it out guys as a special
holiday offer you can get $10 off your
purchase of a skylight frame when you go
to skylight frame comm and enter code
genius that's right to get $10 off your
purchase of a skylight frame just go to
skylight frame comm and enter code
genius that's s KY Li gh t FR a.m. e.com
promo code genius they split up whatever
when I was like 2 years old and then
living over there my dad he I love both
of my parents very much but they both
had different paths you know and I ended
up staying in the south with my dad's
side of the family and my dad you know
he was a heavy drug dealer oh sure he
was a drug dealer for California and for
he was actually banned from California
for seven years so he I can talk about
this now because he's clean and he's
fine he's fine like he was in prison for
12 years holy [ __ ] yeah it was in prison
for 12 years and then he got out right
whenever I got hit with the first
diagnosis ah so my dad and I'm like
daddy's little girl I my I'm my dad's
princess you know so he went 12 years in
prison without me and then comes out and
then he literally two weeks later he
finds out his daughter has cancer she
could die and he's just like what the
[ __ ] you know so growing up going back
to it yeah like growing up my felt like
my life purpose was I want to be a mom I
want to be a parent because even though
I love my parents to death and I had a
great upbringing because of my uncle
took care of me very well my uncle's
like 31 he's like my dad to me my second
dad
but it always made me want to be a
parent and so when that oncologist said
like hey you need to freeze your eggs
the second time around because you're
not going to be you might not be able to
have children that's whenever it hit me
the hardest and it and I didn't let a
lot of people know this but it bothered
me a lot like everyone's like why do you
want to have kids so yeah I'm like you
know this is
something that I've always wanted well
you know you know you know of an end
yeah yeah yeah and so Anna's thing is -
is like it's hard for people to
understand when her she feels like her
life purpose
aside from the businesses that we do
that are highly successful it's for her
to be a parent yeah and nurture somebody
yeah you know and so for her is a hard
pill to swallow when somebody says that
if you want to look at it maybe not in
just having a children sense but
somebody's telling you or gods telling
you or your body's telling you you won't
be able to fulfill your life purpose
yeah and it's a hard pill for her to
swallow yeah and I actually we actually
like private messy each other all the
time in yeah she's so inside she's so
inspirational when it comes to that
because I feel like she can honestly
understand how I'm feeling not a lot of
people might in my friend space a lot of
my best friends they have kids or
they're able to have kids like and it's
a given for them so they don't hurt yeah
and it's it's one of those things that's
been hard to like relate and everything
with them but like I told you even we're
getting better like I've I told you
during the summer that I was I ended up
getting pregnant after my on College
Hill my oncologist told me like you're
not gonna get pregnant and then five
years later I we and I'm getting
pregnant and we were super happy like my
fiance also comes from a broken family
where he was in he was an orphan and
everything and he was in the foster care
system so don't wants to be a father as
well he wants to be at he doesn't know
he's never met his dad and we both want
to be parents so bad and when we see
people who don't even you know it just
hurts and people take that for granted
sometimes like that you have that
because I feel like you know having a
kid is almost seems like a given yeah
the way people talk about it right yeah
when I get a lot of kid but they don't
realize there's some
was that he was some people a lot of
people have trouble Afghans like it's
sometimes it's not in the cards for
people so what well what happened with
your pregnancy so at we were super super
excited and we got a little we got a
little too too excited a little too fast
you know we could we started telling her
like our family and me so we told our
closest friends and we polished
shouldn't but it's because we've been
trying so hard for years and it finally
happened that we can just word vomit and
he wasn't so much at initially he was
really happy but then I was about seven
weeks and he was like you know what I'm
sorry baby like I can't get too invested
because we already had a miscarriage
before so he was just like I can't it
the pain of it I just can't handle it so
I I want to make sure that you get to at
least second trimester where things are
you know the percentages are a little
better and he's so logical and
everything so and I was an unemotional
person so I'm like why aren't you so
invested in this but I understand now
why and it's because at eight weeks we
ended up losing like we end up losing
the baby and now yeah we we lost our
baby and it taught me something but it
wasn't it's not a bad thing it made me
happy and sad it made me happy to know
that my body is functioning again where
and like you want to guess the odd yeah
I went against odds and I my body can
have a baby or you can at least produce
eggs and then it also taught me to it
yeah you know what take I should wait a
little bit until like second trimester
just for myself and him and our family
because we my his family where it was so
heartbroken not to say my my mom's I
wasn't because I would didn't really
open up to my mom's side and it's only
because I didn't want to disappoint her
because it's different you know and I'm
sure you know this Asian parenting and
um you know Western parenting is
different he's Mexican he's white I mean
his Mexican he's not Mexican at all I'm
we're talking Mexican you know and he
it's like they're so excited for us to
have kids and everything but my my mom
and my mom side they're more traditional
you know yeah but now that I opened up
to her and I told her how I feel and
everything we've gone so much closer
well when you found out that you lost
the kid what was going on through your
mind
I just to me it was just like what is
wrong with me and that's why I got super
depressed again I was like what is wrong
with me and and you know and I blame
myself
and I told business I said you know this
is my fault because knowing my situation
my doctors always tell me I'm gonna be
high risk no matter what no matter if it
comes five years from now ten is it will
always be a high-risk pregnancy and
because I also have fibroids near my
uterus as well so there are these it's
like these things that block you and
it's like a common thing females it's
really hard to explain but yeah but yeah
it's it's I feel a lot of blame because
I pushed myself too hard I'm a
workaholic and when it comes down to it
I honestly I'm always working always
grinding and I feel like at that time
when I found out I was pregnant I was
like you know what I probably should
have scaled back my work I probably
shouldn't have worked so hard I probably
shouldn't have stressed and I felt
really guilty and I haven't so grateful
where I have a partner who makes me feel
the opposite what I feel the reason why
you had that miscarriage was because of
yourself and yes
I I feel like it was because I work too
much like I was carrying things like
really you know heavy things and I was
opening myself I mean it's really hard
to say though man yeah I know and and
that's why when I when I saw my OB and I
saw when I actually cuz I went to the
emergency room and they when they told
me everything that's the first thing
that went in my head was like I should
have I shouldn't have carried that case
of water I shouldn't have you know you
blame yourself for these things right
yeah cuz you're carrying a life within
you and and I feel like a connection
that you have with even your unborn
child as a mother you feel that heavy
responsibility no matter what it doesn't
matter
yeah like even before they're born
you've everything that you do in terms
of actions you feel responsible for it
yeah there's a hard pill to swallow for
a lot of people in especially for you
and you know for you to like you know
what you so I can't not too long ago she
messaged me and about something serious
and you know I asked her a few it was
okay for her to share like you you know
you went through a lot of stuff you know
and then there was a moment where you
know for you the option of ending your
life was more plausible than for you to
survive yeah you know I didn't had it
like and the reason why I think it's an
important conversation to have is
because people there's a lot of people
that go through what you go through and
I don't know what that feels like
because I've never felt that way ya know
I don't know what it was about my
upbringing or what I saw that doesn't
get me to that point right no matter
what I go through I think death is
better than living yeah and you cut you
have to kind of think in question my my
my logic where I didn't want to kill
myself when I go had cancer yeah I
didn't want to kill myself the second
time I had cancer I never felt suicidal
whenever my dad was gone for 12 years
you know I didn't feel that whenever you
know I lost everything from Hurricane
Katrina because we lost everything
during Hurricane Katrina well you know
so I never felt those depressed moments
I knew I wasn't a depressed person up
until like the end of last year
beginning of this year what was the
trigger for it what was that elicit the
trigger was it was it was the immense
I'm telling you it hit me like a brick
at the time I wasn't fully getting along
with my family and in a lot of ways and
I'm a very family family is number one
to me yeah and at the time there was a
lot of stuff going on with my family and
then again going back to seeing my
oncologist and having to do PET scans
and then him saying you know what you're
good with the lymphoma but just letting
you know in the future you might have
breast cancer because we gave you so
much radiation in your chest you might
have breast cancer in you know in a
couple years or in 10 years and it was a
combination of all the stress and I and
we I know I have support from family and
friends but I'm a very independent
person I don't like asking for help
and I it was I think everything just
built up it was all of the anxiety from
it's like just one thing after another
it was exactly it was one thing i what
am I going to [ __ ] break
yeah and I think that everything for
some reason I just and and I put on I
put on a lot of people's I'm a lot of
people's go-to person so in that way I
had a lot of struggles I had a lot of
them a lot of struggles with a lot of my
best friends at the time because I'm
always I'm always that person like hey
hey how are you doing are you good you
know are you good how are you feeling
today maybe but I never I never got that
back sometimes and I think that whenever
you know what happened when I try to
commit suicide I felt like I was truly
alone in this world
I said you know what and I told and I
didn't explain this to Ben so many times
and then it was a struggle from he's my
partner yeah and I had to let him know I
feel this way where I think I will be
happier if I wasn't on this world and he
explained to me he goes do you realize
how many people need you in your life
and I can't I couldn't I couldn't order
grasped okay I couldn't I couldn't
accept it I said no and and it was just
so much where I end up trying to do it
and thank God I did it wrong yes you
know to say it in such a like cynical
way I'm glad I did it wrong because I
went I persevered through it um you know
when I was talking to you about your uh
Yoshi Sochi so cat messaged me on
Instagram and I actually met her how did
I meet you I was at a show right yeah
well it's a couple jokes a couple shows
and I met you right and it's it's weird
how sometimes when you're going through
a lot of dark things you you just you
focus on everything that's wrong and
it's very easy to get sucked into that
[ __ ] and what I was telling her was when
she was she she you know just to be
frank and honest and she's okay with
this too is that she attempted to kill
herself like it wasn't like some
foolhardy attempt she actually tried to
kill herself and it didn't work out you
know and from my perspective from what
you were telling me that you were going
through and for somebody who admires you
right you're a fan but you're somebody
that I admire as well
it's very easy to look at your cup half
empty I told you that yeah right cuz but
if I told you what I saw from the
outside it was something that you were
doing that was so admirable but when
you're in this dark space it's so hard
to be your own beacon of life yeah and
you know what and you know what it was
really messed up about it was when I
went to a couple of people that I'm
close with I told them that I was going
through the depression and you know what
they said to me they said what do you
have to be depressed about
you have a house you have dogs you have
a man that doesn't you don't have to
worry about cheating on you because they
know our relationship they're like you
have money you have a career and I go
well thanks I gave me it opened up my
eyes to know who the [ __ ] my real
friends are because they literally asked
me that what do you have to be sad about
this podcast is brought to you by Sunday
scary's my friends Sunday scary's is a
leader in the CBD space they have
created a niche for themselves by
addressing America's anxiety problem my
friends so check it out
they sell amazing wildly effective and
delicious tasting CBD products
especially their CBD gummies so if you
haven't used CBD products before CBD
products are pretty amazing I've been
using them for about two and a half
years now they helped me with my
personal anxiety issues and they helped
me just kind of calm down and get into a
better space and I have been using them
for a good minute even for sparring or
just just everyday life and it feels
great it just helps me to kind of get my
worries away if you haven't tried CBD
products you're missing out on a lot of
things it doesn't really have any
psychoactive effects I'm CBD without the
THC and and I personally love it so if
you guys want to get 50% off
use code brain at Sunday scary's calm
and stop dreading the everyday [ __ ]
in life that doesn't actually matter
remember to get 15% off use code brain
at Sunday scary's calm and stop dreading
the everyday [ __ ] in life that
doesn't actually matter CBD baby all the
way yeah and there's such a terrible way
to look at it because I feel like
sometimes people
they diminish what somebody's going
through at the moment everybody has
these moments where they feel defeated
right and I think like having that
strong support group was great when you
came to me I didn't know what to say
actually yeah I didn't know what to say
the only thing that I could do at the
moment was to tell you like how how you
how I see your cup is full you know and
I didn't want to tell you to like you're
ungrateful that's not that wasn't the
message I was giving you you know what I
wanted to say was like take a step back
and look at how great you're doing like
you're doing you fought cancer twice
that was an opportunity that most people
would kill for you know and the fact
that you survived that [ __ ] and then on
top of that from your cancer I mean I
know this is like maybe me trying to
make a positive spin on things but you
found your passion because of this
cancer yeah yeah you didn't go through
this [ __ ] you would be still working at
a hospital yeah it's so funny you bring
that up because my fiance's friend
Jessica that was his corker before I end
up going because I told you I'm such a
hard worker and I'm always trying to
work yeah before I end up going to chemo
I actually posted on my facebook
Instagram like hey anyone want to place
any orders I'm going for chemo on
Saturday place to order see how yeah and
she was like Ben what the [ __ ] is wrong
with her like this [ __ ] is like why is
she trying to work well that's the thing
they're you know like I like I said like
you're it's for me in your perspective
if you could think about it your cup is
really full you know like I'm not
telling you that in the sense of like oh
look at her she's not grateful for what
she has I'm saying that if you take a
step back from your situation and mind
you you have been through a lot
your father wouldn't your father wasn't
prison for 12 years of your life you
don't have that strong father figure you
want the [ __ ] chemotherapy twice
after you already be cancer but how I
see it is it's like this woman who has
been through all this [ __ ] she's already
coming out on top a lot of people don't
have that you know and I think like for
you it's it's very easy to go into that
dark space and I'll be real with you
like I don't know if I'd be any stronger
than you are I don't know that I don't I
don't know it's very easy to get into
that dark space it is
especially for me when I actually do
everything alone like with my work I'm
home alone I answered inquiries alone
and I look at but I do bookings
everything about about my life is home
base all the time alone and when I own
my when Ben comes home it's like two
three hours and then we're back at it
the next day you know so I think at the
at the time there were a lot of outlets
where we came up with solutions that's
another thing is that he said you know
what I think that what you're lacking is
is a human interaction yeah because he
was like you know you do see your
customers you know everyday you see your
customers but he was like babe you don't
have you know human interaction anymore
and he's like the happiest I ever saw
you was when you were working at the
hospital yeah and I actually worked at
the the cancer floor of the hospital too
so it was great for me because I could
relate to them and I did really great on
that floor but I'd have to agree that I
think that it was the years adding up to
being alone all the time and then still
struggling with and it's even though
it's a little person it doesn't matter I
went with like four years after the
whole cancer thing not having a normal
menstrual cycle yeah so it was like it's
my what is my body doing this why am i
doing this am I gonna like this all
these questions are going through my
head every day still to this day am I
gonna get struck with cancer again you
know am I gonna be able to have a kid am
I going to ever become a mother am I
gonna do this is do I even love baking
you know do I just love baking for the
satisfaction of making people happy
because it doesn't bring me much joy
anymore but I love making people my goal
like my my thing is I love to make
people happy I loved I loved taking care
of people and I feel like sometimes you
put I put myself on that back burner
because I was always taking care of
everyone else you know that's that's the
hard part right like I I think I really
appreciate people who live a life of
servitude and I think like Christianity
has a lot of that [ __ ] into it yeah the
olives in Christianity brought the
Protestant religion where
you live for others versus yourself oh
yeah there's a downside to that because
when you start living for others instead
of yourself there's there's moments when
you are by yourself and you're not
getting that reciprocated appreciation
you feel really alone yeah and it's hard
right even with your friendships right
you're like oh [ __ ] um I didn't think
that these people have my back like I
thought they yeah I'm telling I'm
telling you you would be surprised like
like I said I lost to my clothes like I
said I started friendships here after I
moved here from Hurricane Katrina but
all the friends that I got here right
when I moved to California they've
stayed my friends so ten plus years all
my closest friends under ten people have
stayed my friends but I lost two of my
great friends because of it because I
said not when I explained to the most
going on I actually told them that I try
to commit suicide yeah and they say
that's what they said to me was why they
said you're stupid
you have a you know you have everything
we don't think that you have any reason
to do that and I go you know what I
understand but I at the time I just need
to reach out to you but yeah and that's
and that's what I did for you is that I
feel like because I've been in and I try
to tell people I'm like I've been
watching someone who I look up to and
yeah that has given great advice I
wanted to get advice and I was like by
the same time I had also had another
friend who told me I can't give you
advice because I ain't never been
through this and I understood her I said
if you haven't been through it then I
can't expect advice and there's a lot of
people who you it's it's great it's
actually a great thing that you don't
have a good big circle friends who work
are depressed you know it's a good thing
to say is that good my friends aren't
depressed but it's harder especially but
yeah like I said the person that
definitely helped me through this was
definitely been my family and a couple
of my great friends that it just brought
us closer and it again it's it's it's
hard it's you know hard to talk about
you know I don't really know your
friends that you lost but you know
sometimes people just don't know how to
give advice and some people just don't
know how to listen because a lot
at times what happens is I'm guilty of
this too is that we when we give advice
we put too much of ourselves into it and
we lack that empathy when somebody's
hurting right because what they see is
what happens is when somebody talks down
to somebody when they're going through
think going through something they go
you have nothing to worry about
right look at what I'm going through and
I'm not complaining about that [ __ ] so
they they put themselves in a position
that you're in without being empathetic
and without reaching out you know and
what happens that is that you minimize
how somebody feels right yeah some
people take that to the stream we're
like where they're not really minimizing
how they feel and they get exaggerated
with their [ __ ] but in times like this I
think that it's hard for people to
understand when it's when you need to
listen and when you need to give advice
yeah because listening is a lot of the
times is what people just mean they
don't you can't say you can't solve
other people's problems sometimes yeah
they don't want an answer back they
don't want to answer they just want a
literally an ear to listen to yeah just
be there for me and support me right
because even when you contact me like I
don't know you want that close of a
personal level a lot of the stuff I'm
just finding out right now mm-hm right
but in that moment I'm just like okay
for somebody to reach out to me who
doesn't know me very well she must be
going through some real [ __ ] right for
me I met you and you know you're a very
positive human being and you're really
great to be around so I'm like there
must be something that she's really
going to him when you told me you you
actually tried to kill yourself and I'm
like what is this girl going through
right now that her perspective is
slipped because how I see her is
completely different from how she sees
herself and that's yeah and that's the
thing is like a lot of people who end up
finding out later on again not a lot of
people know but I'm very open now to I'm
in my 20s
yeah they were like it's your fault it's
your fault it was it's not it's not my
mom's less than my dad saw it's how I
feel you're dealing with yeah I was
dealing with a lot and it's hard for a
parent though man yeah and I think both
of them they just kind of kept they were
fighting with each other like you know
it's your fault because you weren't
there for it's no it's your fault
because you weren't there it was it was
a battle between them but at the end of
the day
I've gotten much closer to both of them
and especially my mom because my mom and
I we didn't have the closest I didn't
grow up with her in California but right
now who raised you then my grandma
because that's a huge [ __ ] shout out
to [ __ ] Asian grandmas Abba noise
like thank you for being around Thank
You binoy and help picking up the pieces
man and my own a my and my uncle kit kit
he he was my dad for me and during that
time and I was you know when he found
out that Charlie came myself the first
thing he did was come over here yeah
that's the first thing and he was in
Texas and yeah he I have a I'm so
grateful to her and really blessed that
I have closest family as I do especially
my dad side it's very very close I'm not
saying that my mom's not the same but
it's just that southern hospitality no
judgment that slow slow paced life where
it's really eating when it comes to both
of my my mom's side my dad's side yes
they're both so different and after that
whole situation I think my mom and I got
very close and it was one of those
things that I had come to realize too
was there was anger that I had towards
her because I thought that when I was a
kid she left me you know I thought that
you know what little resentment yeah
resentment there and as I get older I
realize I I tell my siblings all the
time because I'm the oldest of all them
and it's a huge break to of age gaps but
I told him I said you know what as I get
older I understand I it took a long time
for me to fully understand but I
understand why if my mom or my dad
whatever situation it was if my mom had
to leave and she couldn't take care of
me at the time or they had a
disagreement look imagine when she was
going today yeah at that she was 16 you
know I understand I can't even imagine
you know but then she had my sister
Vivian and then Vanessa about a couple
years later so it's so [ __ ] funny my
assistant / former assistant her name is
[ __ ] Vanessa and her sister
social name is [ __ ] Vivian yeah and
and it's funny cos bins like those are
promiscuous like I'll never name my kids
be names because they're promiscuous as
hell a we have one with the name we show
everybody had to have the name and I
wanna just tell you this my I love my
sister isn't one of my best friend's
she's she's like a couple years younger
than me and she's like CAD you're gonna
be she's are you're gonna be honest it's
just a lot of my friends they watch this
and I was like I was like will be what
do you want just something is just like
I was like all right I feel let's see
but yeah she she's she's great she's
actually the only family member that I
end up telling about my my pregnancy
this year on my mom's side so I didn't
even tell my mom that Ben and I got
pregnant and so she found out the bad
news I told Vivian I said can you tell
mom the that I had a miscarriage and if
I'm a little off these next couple weeks
or if I'm distant from her it's not her
it's not her and my sister she was great
and she told my mom and I'm and then the
response I got back from my mom from
Vivian was you know what I wish you
would have told me the good news and
that at that moment I was like yeah you
know you know what it is - it's funny
that you mentioned that because I had a
conversation with my mom because you
know my brother is going through some
[ __ ] right now
mm you know and parents just want to be
included yeah whether it's the good or
the bad because when they're not
included in the bed they felt like their
felt failing as parents because they
just want to be there for you yeah you
know and a lot of the times I think for
independent human beings we think that
we always had to be strong on our own
and it and it almost feels awkward to
reach out for help yeah yeah like you're
a burden to people yeah and so what
happens with that when you feel like
you're a burden you you kind of lose
your own support group you you you know
it's it's hard when a broken person
tries to heal them in a broken person
it's very [ __ ] difficult and
sometimes to want a broken human being
feels like they had to be independent
and strong they don't know who to reach
out to and it leaves you in a very just
vulnerable and bad place and
because you you are the support group or
somebody else you don't want to ask them
for support yeah never yeah I I always
like I said and I always kept things
inside because I have I feel like it's
my duty and my obligation to be the
strong one for my family and friends and
but like I said that was one of my
regrets this year it's not telling my
mom that hey mom Ben and I she wants to
be there with ya and and now that and
now that that we went through that and
that happened in like June so a couple
months ago I now my mom it's it's in
freakin makes me just want to cry
sometimes thing about it but when I'm on
the phone with her she just got a [ __ ]
kink or so Oh
yesterday they got a little puppy and
she's just like he's gonna be so spoiled
you know up until you and Ben have a kid
and just her saying that because she's
so traditional she's she's so you know
that agent they want you to experience
life before you have kids her saying
that it made me feel so it's like happy
sad cuz I'm just like I never thought I
would hear my mom say like I want you
and Ben to have kids because for a
couple years she was like hold off hold
off you know experience life but Ben and
I we had different as we had different
thoughts about how to live your life
like where we are we like to travel but
not hers honestly they were very like
home homey and we like to spend time
with our family and our dogs and we're
just very home like cozy home and I try
to explain to her that I don't want to
go out and experience like go travel
that's not really what I want to do in
my life I want to just have you know how
my friends have my family had kids and I
know that might be a little weird
concept for some people but I don't
wanna got their own yeah I don't I don't
have that thing to like travel and I
still yeah just if just for her to hear
her say like you know you I you guys
gonna be having kids just for her to say
that it's it's a very groundbreaking and
I and maybe it doesn't sound
groundbreaking but for someone like me
to hear her not be okay with having kids
for so you know so many years
and putting it down for her to say bring
that up it was a monumental moment for
me and it made me cry when I got home
and I said I can't believe now she takes
us she takes this seriously she doesn't
underplay that I can't have children you
know I you know I did a video on this
and I think it was a concept that I
started to learn as I got older was that
there's a couple things number one
everybody is going through something you
know even some of the people who are
outwardly and externally happy they're
going through some [ __ ] what I found out
is that happiness takes a lot of effort
you have to choose to see the good good
in things because it's very easily
caught up in your own [ __ ] it's very
easy to cop in the bad things in life
happiness takes a lot of [ __ ] effort
you know and I because I started to
invoke that in my life if your things
got better yeah you know like I have to
understand that even to the basic things
right ten fingers ten toes I don't have
issues with mental disability like some
other people do I don't have autism I
don't have a short limb I have vision i
have sight I can speak these are the
things that I really have to be grateful
for
yeah because some people don't have that
[ __ ] you know and it's so easy to get
caught up in all this [ __ ] that's
why when I saw your situation I'm just
like would you see when you were when
you were thinking about killing yourself
was like oh man like I got the [ __ ] and
mistake but what I saw was a woman who
has been able to create her own business
out of some kind of tragedy that
happened her life and how I see it now
and maybe it's because of my perspective
is that like I said before where would
you have been without that cancer yeah I
know where would you have been without
that trial and tribulation that forced
you to do something that you really
loved and now it's your [ __ ] career
I know hazy like I the business the
people that I started doing orders for
like five six years ago I it's my
business is so great to where I do
they're doing their gender reveal and
then their baby shower and then all of a
sudden is their first birthday then
their second birthday
third and I've been a part of someone's
family now for six years like doing
consistently doing their new kids and
it's like it's so rewarding to where I
was like you know what the satisfaction
that I got from working at the hospital
it's kind of the same whenever whenever
I pick up my phone that next day and I
asked my clients hey how was everything
and they say you made our party
everything cat-like I've had customers
change their party date to have my
desserts and it's like I don't realize
how big it is just because I don't work
you know and I forget that and I don't
know how to accept that I've created
something like that imagine like imagine
how just creating simple desserts really
affects somebody in a positive way if
you weren't around and you decided to
kill yourself people wouldn't have those
moments that's how you affect people
yeah really think about that [ __ ] yeah
I'm doing it people have those moments
and I know for you I sometimes when you
when you feel sad and you're down and
you get swallowed up by these dark
thoughts I'm telling you man like people
have to realize like they really do have
an effect on other people's lives when
when you find purpose and you find that
purpose and you're grounded in it people
search their whole lives for that [ __ ]
cat people who are 70 80 years old they
still don't know who the [ __ ] they are
yeah I don't know that [ __ ] they still
search for it and they're still trying
to be something but they're not they're
trying to mold into what other people
wanted them because when they were
younger they didn't take the time to
figure out who they are and I'm somebody
who truly believes that trials and
tribulations are a must in their life to
shape who you are as a human being no
and I and it's funny because I I tell
people this me and Ben tell people this
all the time me and him have every
reason not every reason but we've had
we've been through so much so many
things in our life what we could be a
piece of [ __ ] to be in society and to
people but we don't like we have because
I know a lot of people are like I've
been through this I've been through this
I can't you know I just can't do it
because and I and my and I'm not trying
to not judging anyone but in my opinion
is if you can identify what your
miss or you know what that is you should
try to work on it and not use it as a
crutch for your whole life you know like
that's easy to do easy route exactly so
like everyone's like you know you with
your dad they're like you didn't have a
dad do you have daddy issues
hell no my I was like you know I didn't
see my dad I got to fit I had made me
visit him like twice would yeah during
the 12 years but I still think my father
is an amazing father and I said I could
have I could have daddy issues mommy
issues everything but I I don't and
that's really admirable right because
some sometimes even for me it's hard for
me to sit down and say I call it
personal responsibility right there are
things that happen in your life that you
couldn't control but at the end of the
day with your actions you have still
you're still personally responsible for
the things that you do and the way that
you behave it sucks that you had the
[ __ ] hand in life right yeah you got
dealt a [ __ ] hand but now after you move
past that it's up to you to figure out
how you're gonna conduct yourself
through the rest of your life because I
have a friend too mad negative this this
do mad [ __ ] negative right and I
understand it was terrible but how I say
this too is that at the end of the day
after you're done explaining to to
everybody else why your life is [ __ ] and
you keep expressing these negative
negative thoughts and you have all these
bad habits that's why people don't
[ __ ] care they don't care they're not
gonna want to be around you yeah right
and then you lose your support group
friends can be empathetic make it
sympathize with you but nobody wants to
be around somebody who always wants to
pensar yeah the pity party [ __ ] doesn't
[ __ ] matter at the end of the day
that's why I love comedy right yo people
say [ __ ] to all the time they go yo man
like I love your comedy he was like but
you know when I say my comedy stuff when
you look back at a lot of this [ __ ] just
tragic you know getting your ass beat as
a kid you know being poor you know being
impoverished you think that's just funny
it's not know but I but I put a flip on
it you know because I can't sit here and
wallow in self defeat because I can't
live that way I refuse to live that way
you know so that thought of being
gracious and grateful for what you have
very important because it puts things in
perspective you know and I'll go back to
same for you man like you you that
cancer though it was a tragedy in your
life it actually turned out to be a
blessing it's a huge [ __ ] blessing
without that [ __ ] would you have started
this business no honestly no I literally
went from like I said my oncologist
saying hey we don't it's a risk for you
to work in like a work environment you
might faint you might get a little boozy
I said all right what can I do because I
first I got I still got bills to pay
yeah and I'm not gonna ask people for
money what it did it took you out of
your comfort zone forced you to find
your passion like I wanted my funny but
if you look at my Instagram page from
like the very very very start of my
desert it was trash like I I look at it
we're just looking at it and I'm like
pupil yeah and then a year a couple
years later and then I'm looking at my
work I'm like [ __ ] I improved you know
and every day like Ben's telling me like
he was like you don't realize that you
you like blow me away every single time
you come up with this new desert or this
new design he's like he was like you
surprise me every day because he knows
that this wasn't my path he knows that
he knows I know and for your friends out
there too that you lost I don't think
they came from a negative when they made
they came from a negative place because
they felt like you're being ungrateful
but I essentially am saying the same
thing that they're saying but I passed
Packaging in a better way they should
have learned how to talk to human beings
yeah you know and and the way they're
coming out from it is from I hate that
comes from a personal issue that they
had that they're projecting onto you and
you know what you're told right because
when I lost them and I told Ben about it
you know what he told me he said you are
seeking advice from two people who don't
even has never even lived life he still
lives at home with their parents who's
never gone out of their comfort zone
he's never had they can't relate to you
yeah that's what he was saying he was
like he was like hon you you're looking
for the wrong you were looking for the
wrong people they can't give you advice
like that you know it's amazing that you
have somebody in your life that's a
pillar for you you know
that's not good awesome yeah he I'm
telling you I honestly I truthfully
would not be here if it wasn't important
I'm saying like when I really see your
your glass is half-full you know it's I
mean you've been through a lot more than
most people have you know and the fact
that you chose to stick it out and stay
around it's amazing man and that's the
reason why I really wanted to bring you
on this podcast is for people who go out
there and feel what you feel and they
haven't even been through half of what
you've been through you know and you and
you're choosing to stick around and I'm
telling you like after after all this
happened I'm not gonna lie this year has
after that has been happy I'm good
perspective like I am after everything
after all I should I have a better
relationship with my mom you have a
better relationship with Ben I have
better leadership with my friends the
friends I you know that stayed with me
with my even my customers and my clients
they were concerned for me because they
need something that's how close I am
with my clients yeah I have a
relationship with them when they when
they're text me how I'm feeling and I
wasn't answering they knew something was
off because I'm very open with my
clients and and I see my clients as some
of like more than just clients as
friends because I'm in their life I'm
doing parties for their whole family and
they're concerned for me and that's when
Ben told me he's like your he was like
if you think that no one's going to be
sad if you were to in your life he was
like it's [ __ ] yeah it was like not
just me he said not your family not your
everybody
everyone everyone that have you have
impacted and I had to think about it and
I'm like you know what I feel like a
damn hypocrite right now because with
his job I'm always telling him honey at
least you have a job at least you get
overtime at least you have this you have
this like it's easier to give advice
yeah yeah so when I thought about I was
like I'm being a hypocrite right now man
I'm like I'm always telling him look at
the brighter side look at this look at
that and then when he's telling me this
I wasn't accepting it I was just like no
no no like people will be better off
without me and then now this year
everything is good like it's good if I
were to ask you you know before we in
this podcast
you know somebody who is going through
what you went through and what you're
going through with those suicidal
thoughts what's a piece of advice that
you could give them to help change their
perspective on their life I would
there's a couple things I would say
honestly for my advice to someone who's
going through your own whatever issue it
is where its fertility where it's just
depression or anything like that
you have a lot of people or even if it's
not a lot of people that one person that
there's one person out there who needs
you and who loves you and they can't go
on without even imagining life without
you just that little just even if it's
one person that one person is enough
that they care so much about you that
they don't want they can't even imagine
life without you yeah and even like
there's so many outlets that I think
people can go to and like I said friends
family sometimes it's someone that you
don't even really know but you felt like
you felt compelled to add to get advice
from them just like that I reached out
to you oh you know I reached out to Anna
and Jeremy I reached out to Jess even
and I said I know I don't know you guys
like that but I feel like I need advice
and it actually helped it really every
single person that gave me advice
it helped tremendously and another
outlet like it's I'm not trying to
freaking plug in anyone's [ __ ] but I'm
not gonna lie you can been Mattel anyone
a lot of things I made me in my spirits
happy with my friends and family but
then I'm not kidding you your this
channel yeah JK Tim's channel anything
that was comedy anything just listening
to just some just listening you guys
[ __ ] and talk off the record it
helps and I think that some I don't know
if you guys know this but for me it
helped me a lot during my during
everything like just while I'm working
that shit's on for hours yeah and like I
said I'm not trying to plug
but it really you guys don't realize how
much you guys help other people not just
in California in the city all over the
world people are watching you guys and
you guys are helping they they might be
[ __ ] depressed one morning sad angry
they [ __ ] flip that channel on they
watch you guys and they're like holy
[ __ ]
my mood is completely changed I'm happy
I'm smiling I'm laughing yeah and just
little things like that like finding
outlets or even just holding on to
someone that cares about you
cuz there there's always someone who
cares about you and it's looking out for
you well your well-being yeah I don't
believe that there's one person out
there who's like I have no one you do
have someone you just just to summarize
that up it's just like finding that
support group and appreciating the
people that are around you doesn't have
to be a lot of people but you know your
life matters yeah yeah it really does
I'm special thing your life really
matters and you'd be surprised like your
death how it affects somebody yeah it
affects them some people you may not
think it because you're in a bad place
in your life but perspective is
everything you know and and I and I
always say it like this you know and I
use photos as a great example right when
I take photos of people they look at it
like I don't like this angle you know I
don't like this
and then my post is photo you know
everybody comments like yo this is
amazing photo they don't like that side
of themselves because they're so used to
putting up a front and they try to show
a side of themselves that you know
really is it honestly you yeah you know
and what I say is too it's like when I
post a photo of you that's you know when
I edit the photo it takes me like you
know 20 30 minutes to edit this photo
and the reason why I posted a few it's
not so much because it's your best angle
it's because I'm trying to show the
qualities that I love about you right
the things that things that you don't
see in yourself the people that love you
see all that [ __ ] when you when you wake
up and you feel like you know I don't
feel beautiful
just when were the people people who
love you they always think that you're
beautiful
yeah it's it's if you have really good
friends you know I come
like geo I loved you geo to me is like
one of those people who I feel like if I
wanted an older sister in my life she'd
be the one she would be the one right
and for her when I look at her man she's
I think like I mean she's beautiful not
even in the physical sense she's
physically very beautiful everybody
[ __ ] doing yeah but I even told her I
was like there are times where I don't
even want you to talk I just want to be
around you just because I feel comforted
around you right and that's that's who
she is as a person she's such a loving
and empathetic person you know but you
know sometimes it's hard for people to
see those qualities in themselves but
everybody around you feels that [ __ ]
yeah and I think I think that's what I
had to accept I accept I had to accept
that and there there are times when you
you have so many people telling you that
you're you're so caring of so empathetic
and then it made me again this is during
my depression I internalized han ago all
these things that I do for people am i
doing it genuinely for them or am i
doing it for myself and then a lot of
people like Kat what are you talking
about you're not doing it for yourself
you're doing it for others but then
there's that twisted part of you where I
thought to myself am I genuinely doing
this for for that person or is it to
make me feel good you know and I think
that's another another thing that I
questioned myself with but I can say
that I am I that is my definite life
purpose that's a great thing that
helping oh yeah that's awesome well you
know I gotta tell you man for no one
thank you for coming on and sharing the
story it's a hard thing I was trying to
get you one like a couple months ago but
you know I've been traveling so much but
I just wanted to be in the right space
to be able to share the story with
people because it's important man and
you know you you surprise like you're
not the first person they hit me up with
you know suicidal thoughts and it's
humbling the fact that somebody will
reach out to me but I get scared too
because I don't want to give the wrong
advice yeah cuz I don't know what it
feels like you know like I've had
moments where I felt like my life was
worthless but I never thought about
taking my own life yeah and hopefully
this [ __ ] could help other people out
you know I hope so too yeah like I said
it's it like out of all the things I've
been through
there was not nothing there was nothing
last year around that time in it last
year then of December January or
anything really traumatic happened so
that's why I some people need to realize
is nothing really like needs to be
traumatic a good event then he said did
you like a train there was nothing at
that time that like hit me like a train
I was like [ __ ] you know it was just all
the sudden I just started thinking do
you think thank you because you're so
independent you're trying to be strong
on your own all that she's just yes up
and I just can crash it a hundred
percent a hundred percent I try not to
tell my fiance everything that's going
on because he works so much and I don't
want to do that I don't want to put so
much stress on him I don't want to go to
my family because I need to be strong
for them and my siblings I mean I'm the
strong person for my friends and I think
that I just needed I needed someone at
that time around that time I needed
someone to ask me hey how are you doing
and I think that's the one thing that if
anything you can take away from this is
check up on your strong friends guys
like check up on your strong friends
your strong friends they might be going
through some [ __ ] and the simple thing
that's the simplest thing is hey how are
you doing today like I miss you I hope
you're doing well
that makes a difference and someone that
is strong and tries to be independent
and try not to involve anyone in their
problems it's just asking them how
you're doing and it helps you know well
my face is a good place in the podcast
man our in-house amazing man I mean by
that yeah I'm a cat where can they find
you cat sweets I like I said it's not
like if people are like like I'm a part
of like Jose Jamal yo people's like and
and it's funny before this even happened
I told him I'm like I'm mad nervous I
have anxiety I was like I need like the
support and love and there's and his his
whole citizens of Jamal yeah there's
some of the most supportive people ever
like they were just telling me like
you know what you're good you're good
you got it and I was just filled with
anxiety and I told Ben this too I said I
don't have a problem opening up and
telling you especially you how I feel in
what I've been through it's that I'm
nervous on what other people are gonna
see in here and because I've never
because like you just said where can you
find me it's I'm not a social media
person I'm not I'm really like I don't
have any influence and like that I'm not
on YouTube I'm not on anything like that
so I'm just so I was telling everyone
I'm afraid of what I'm gonna see in the
comments like if people are gonna be
negative you know because I never had to
deal with that but I'm just but I got a
lot of good advice and prove it it's
like [ __ ] you know there's gonna be
haters no matter what you're successful
people always ask because they're not
happy with what where they are in their
life
but yeah but yeah you know you don't I
have the only social media I have is my
private which I am NOT gonna add you
guys on but I have my my desert page is
cats underscore sweets underscore and I
don't know I just can't check that out
guys anyways man you could catch us on
Spotify podcast any kind of online
platforms you're our iTunes give us that
five style we're trying to reach that 3k
likes and yeah man like I thought like I
told you guys if it's your first time
listening to this podcast this podcast
is never about celebrities and what you
know their personal stories and lives
everybody has a great personal story
it's just about opening up and I want
people to relate to people in this
podcast you know you know I think
sometimes the us want major and huge
guests which I could get anytime but I
want to bring people on here that I
resonate with the most even if they
don't have a huge following it doesn't
matter to me man and um you know
hopefully this helps somebody out and if
you got are going through that those
feelings of you know feeling alone and
you want to end your life just know that
you know you're not the only one going
through that [ __ ] you know it's a
constant thought that a lot of people
have you know I think I'm blessing the
fact that I haven't thought of that [ __ ]
but it's it's more common than it's not
and you're not alone either man there's
there's a lot of energy that you could
put into to looking at the negative
things in your life but if you flip that
[ __ ] and you look at how great things
are going for you like I said even the
small [ __ ] I look at my I have eyeballs
as
yeah I could speak yeah you know I had a
roof over my head food in my stomach I
got [ __ ] ten fingers and ten toes I
know that sounds so [ __ ] stupid to a
lot of you know it's everything but
gratitude grounds you and it gives you
great perspective so anyways guys thank
you guys for listening and we'll catch
you next time David broke his diet I did